even have this like from from a
biological standpoint this like kind of
group mentality so when they see other
women doing certain things and getting
success off it then they feel like you
know you need to emulate that to be in
this group and hence the BBL culture
hence the BBL culture makeup blowing up
your lips etc etc so you don't want to
be ostracized from any group and if you
see a certain group of women getting
success doing certain things and you
think okay that's what I need to do to
get the man that I want it's a similar
it's the same thing with what men men
will say we want natural women who have
natural beauty but in women will say but
you the girl with the fake bum in the
big box yes that was a thing or a Wi-Fi
and and again we say this on a regular
basis there's certain women that we
there's a caliber woman that would
[ __ ] a caliber woman that would wear
we told you the caliber women that we'd
wife but you see what we go for in terms
of just quick interactions and you seem
to assume that that is what men want
women